françois truffaut est mort cet
après-midi ce grand cinéaste français
avait 52 ans colère et indignation en
france après la condamnation de jacques
à bouchard à 18 ans de prison en
afghanistan le chargé d'affaires
français a pu le voir ce matin à kaboul
deux explosions la nuit dernière en
région parisienne action directe
revendiquent les deux attentats à la
france que remporte le grand prix du
portugal de formule 1 mais le champion
du monde et lipides haute niki lauda qui
termine deuxième dans stade 2 2e dès
20h20 les dernières images et les
derniers résultats sportifs de la
journée là monsieur bonsoir la nouvelle
est tombée il y à un quart d'heure à
peine le grand cinéaste français
françois truffaut est mort cet après
midi à l'hôpital américain de neuilly il
avait 52 ans et il était atteint d'un
cancer
oui françois truffaut qui a commencé on
le sait par être un excellent et
virulent par son fils des condoms pour
aboutir aux honneurs une critique 18 ans
des cahiers du cinéma celui qui
vilipendait le cinéma de papa et le
festival de cannes monthey quelques
années plus tard sur la scène pour
recevoir le grand prix dans les 400
coups de françois truffaut raconter sa
jeunesse difficile à travers un masque
le visage de jean pierre léaud et un
pseudonyme
antoine doinel qu'il garda pendant 20
ans
qu'est ce que tu dis il faut juste me
from pas seulement j'ai dû me demande
mais le français que tant les spurs a
donc tu as besoin de 300 m le s'emballe
car la 520 mon principe c'est un mec
super satellite iso où sont passés les
et puis y'a pas toi vie
et puis j'ai pas loin en tout cas des
devoirs qu'on a c'est fabuleux raisons
profondes en place et les va-t-en-guerre
allez l'amour à vingt ans baisers volés
domicile conjugal l'amour en fuite film
plaisant ou attendre y montrait son
visage serein et ses petits grammes mais
ces épisodes alterné avec des histoires
désespéré hanté par l'amour fatale et
ses dangereuses apothéose la sirène du
mississipi à des lâches
jules et jim la peau douce où la femme
d'à côté
car truffaut c'était à la fois un jeune
homme timide souriante cedella est un
romantique puritains croyants à l'amour
fou que seuls peuvent finir la folie ou
la mort il admirait à la fois et un
styliste roi de la comédie et du coq
maître de l'angoissé
il y avait chez lui du père de famille
et de l'amant un amant dans les silences
cachets des orages inattendu et un père
attentif qui savait parler aux ans
faire parler les enfants comme parlait
les deux filles que lui avait donné sa
femme madeleine
tu vas me plie cjd j'adore me dépasser
la voilà maintenant tu vas dormir enfin
moi je filme surtout les relations
sentimentales hommes femmes et les
relations parents enfants
alors ce choix de matériel affectif
m'amène évidemment avoir souvent au son
de l'écran des femmes des enfants plus
que des hommes que son prix quand même
par leurs activités sociales discret
même secret françois mallet le cinéma à
sa vie et abriter sa vie derrière le
cinéma sa passion de l'image était telle
qu'il pouvait prendre l'avion pour aller
voir avec ce projet un film rare pendant
deux heures est certes il aima plus
qu'un simple metteur en scène ses
interprètes
jeanne moreau catherine deneuve ou fanny
ardant dont il eu une autre fille il
s'était tissé un cocon protéger ou
nordiste est cécile ou produit par lui
avec les mêmes insistant les mêmes amis
scénariste dans un bureau plein de
reliques et de piles de livres car il
écrivit aussi des livres aux noix
ensuite score en faveur du film de
personnages c'est à dire quand le
personnage est très vivant on a besoin
d'eau d'histoire ou de mois d'action et
j'aime assez les films deux personnages
où les personnages sont importants il
était aimé des gens de cinéma de ses
amis de la nouvelle vague il accueillait
d'une âme égale l'échec où le succès
il avait surtout du succès petit homme
noir devenu gris il avait créé son monde
en faisant le tour de son coeur éclairé
comme une planète d'un côté ombre et
d'un côté lumière fait de vous sa
prisonnière mais si quelqu'un vous dis
simplement il est là je vous l pourquoi
ne pas l'écouter benzema mois des mégots
brive où cela s'est vraiment délai ni
les rennais n'ont hélas non ces
paroisses et le dr sanders pour les dict
je vais vous dire quelque chose sur sur
le docteur sands
voilà comment les payer ça criait alors
jouer comme ça cette scène mois
seulement pas du tout pas non plus cher
le septième rang par trois les parents
des 400 coups son dernier film vivement
dimanche
françois truffaut a donc réalisé l'une
des plus belles et des plus durables
oeuvre du cinéma français françois
truffaut je vous le rappelle avait 52
ans
voilà trente quatre jours que jacques à
bouchard est prisonnier des forces
soviéto afghane en afghanistan hier
après un simulacre de procès un tribunal
révolutionnaire afghan l'a condamné à 18
ans de prison pour avoir franchi
illégalement la frontière dans le seul
but d'exercer son métier
ce matin l' agence de presse afghane aux
et qualifiés de libres et démocratiques
l'atmosphère dans laquelle s'était
déroulé ce procès un procès à la
sauvette sans les avocats commis par la
famille et sans la présence d'un
représentant de l'ambassade de france
ce matin pour la première fois depuis
l'arrestation de jacques à bouchard le
chargé d'affaires de france à kaboul a
pu enfin le voir dans des circonstances
dont les conditions ne sont pas
officiellement précisée par le quai
d'orsay
le médecin de l'ambassade de france en
tout cas n'a pas eu l'autorisation de
l'examiner le chargé d'affaires français
aussi exprimé aux autorités de kaboul
l'indignation du gouvernement français à
l'annonce de cette condamnation sans
précédent
le porte parole du gouvernement roland
dumas qui tenait cet après midi une
conférence de presse a réaffirmé la
détermination des autorités à obtenir la
libération de jacques bouchard en cette
condamnation
permettez moi de vous le dire est
inadmissible injustifiable et
injustifiée le gouvernement dès le
premier jour c'est pour occuper vous le
savez du sort de l'acca bouchard mais
depuis que la nouvelle est tombée c'est
à dire depuis hier à redoubler de
vigilance et d'efforts ne se passe pas
un jour où il ne se passera pas un jour
sans que nos pressions s'exercent à la
fois sur le gouvernement de kaboul et
sur le gouvernement soviétique et j'ai
bon espoir
j'ai vraiment très bon espoir que ces
efforts aboutissent rapidement
je m'en réjouis par avance pour
l'ensemble de votre profession en tout
cas au delà des contacts diplomatiques
toutes sortes de démarches officielles
et officieuses sont en cours ainsi
georges marchais a fait savoir ce matin
qu'il était intervenu auprès du
gouvernement afghan
unanimes les personnalités politiques
disent leur indignation
la condamnation prononcée contre jacques
à bouchard et révoltant
c'est une caricature de justice j'ajoute
qu'elle est sans importance parce que
comme elle n'a pas de valeur juridique
bien entendu il ne doit pas interrompre
en rien les efforts entrepris pour
obtenir la libération du journaliste
français alors que nous avons une
sanction hors de proportion à l'évidence
est donc strictement politique et dont
la responsabilité incombe de 7 tout à
fait évident aux autorités soviétiques
tout ça vraiment scandaleux c'est un
déni défi au change le plus élémentaire
des droits que je crois qu'il faut
montrer clairement au gouvernement
afghan et éventuellement à ceux qui
peuvent inspirer ses actes que une telle
mesure dans son caractère à la fois
inique et brutal peut peser sur les
relations est ouest est en tout cas sur
les relations bilatérales de la france
nous souhaitons que jacques à bouchard
soit le plus rapidement possible le
libérer retrouve sa famille et son
activité et dès ce matin
le parti communiste français a
officiellement fait savoir que son
secrétaire général georges marchais
intervenait après cette condamnation à
nouveau auprès des autorités afghanes
pour réitérer sa demande de libération
dans les meilleurs délais de jacques
bouchard dans un texte qui sera publié
demain par le journal libération
plusieurs intellectuels demande aux
français et aux personnels politiques de
la majorité comme de l'opposition de
manifester ensemble pour exiger la
libération de jacques à bouchard et à
travers lui le respect du droit à
l'information
de son côté le comité pour la libération
de jacques à bouchard appelle les
journalistes et les personnalités qui
sont conviés à boycotter les diverses
cérémonies prévues pour marquer
l'anniversaire des relations franco
soviétique le 26 octobre prochain et la
fête nationale soviétique du 6 novembre
le comité demande aussi audience au chef
de l'état et écrit au président du sénat
et de l'assemblée nationale pour que le
parlement unanime prennent position sur
cette affaire
par ailleurs la fédération suisse des
journalistes protestent contre le
verdict qualifié de barbares
verdict rendu donc à l'encontre de
jacques à bouchard deux attentats en
moins de douze heures malgré les
arrestations de certains de ses membres
et la surveillance de la police le
groupe dissous action directe a
manifesté sa vitalité à montrouge et à
saint cloud la nuit dernière
françoise champey ya 21h25 explosion
d'une forte puissance la cible messier
hispano bugatti une entreprise
travaillant pour le compte de la défense
nationale c'est le service informatique
qui a été particulièrement endommagés
tout le rez-de-chaussée a été soufflée
trois blessés légers
l'attentât est revendiqué par action
directe
et puis ce matin 6 heures à saint cloud
ce sont les établissements marcel
dassault qui sont visés une bombe d'un
kilo placés à proximité d'une citerne de
gaz a dévasté les bureaux brisé toutes
les vitres et arraché les arbres jusqu'à
100 mètres à la ronde
le maire de saint cloud s'est tout de
suite rendu sur les murs
en 81 82 une phase de laxisme tout à
fait regrettable dans n'auront pas cessé
de payer les inconvénients
parmi les bénéficiaires de l'amnistié
1981 jean marc rouillan fondateur aux
visages multiples d'action directe et
son amie nathalie ménigon
le nouveau gouvernement socialiste
espère obtenir une trêve des mouvements
gauchistes arrêté en mars 1981 ménigon
et rouillan ne reste que quelques mois
en prison en effet ils sont amnistié et
libéré en août 1981 mais des 82 malgré
la dissolution du mouvement les
attentats reprennent le 21 août deux
artificiers sont tués en essayant de
désamorcer une bombe avenue de la
bourdonnais à paris 1984 l'étau se
resserre sur les activistes du mouvement
dissout février à levallois-perret
découverte d'un véritable arsenal
appartenant à un action directe mars
1984 coup de filet régissent les chairs
et aliette baisses sont arrêtés dans une
villa près d'avignon juillet 1984 les
révélations d'une militante repenti
permettent à la police de découvrir une
nouvelle planque d'action directe rue
manuel à paris c'est sur la base de ces
mêmes indications que le juge bruguière
inculpé régissent les chairs et les
frères claude et nicolas l'fun déjà sous
les verrous pour le meurtre de deux
policiers avenue trudaine à paris le 31
mai 1983
depuis le 15 septembre cinq grévistes de
la faim à la prison de fresnes il
réclame d'être regroupés pour mieux
préparer leur défense
il s'agit de vincenzo ce panneau régis
fleischer aliette baisse
claude et nicolas halphen
avant-hier deux arrestations daniel
francke un jeune romancier et paula
jacques journaliste à france inter
tous deux sont inculpés d' association
de malfaiteurs et pourtant leur rôle
dans les activités d'action directe est
loin d'être établi aujourd'hui
la police est toujours à la recherche de
jean marc rouillan père historique du
mouvement action directe et de son amie
nathalie ménigon l'actualité politique
de ce dimanche est d'autant plus
marquante que pour la première fois
depuis très longtemps on a pu voir
côte-à-côte valéry giscard d'estaing et
l'un de ses anciens premiers ministres
jacques chirac il assistait ensemble à
la clôture du conseil national du parti
républicain qui a reconduit françois
léotard dans ses fonctions de secrétaire
général
en revanche l'autre ancien premier
ministre raymond barre était absent et
ses partisans l'ont rejoint dans la
mayenne une journée en trois actes
jean-louis lecesne acte l'inde a ajourné
les léotard vient et d'encrés penser le
conseil national du père du toqué de
disques a accueilli le respirateur
plusieurs actes de jacques chirac qui a
accepté l'invitation arrivages -12
l'accueil est moins chaleureux mais
l'opération unitaire est immédiatement
récupéré par le fait hacker général qui
vient d'être renouvelé l'espérance que
nous avons mes chers amis c'est de voir
un certain soir de printemps de l'année
1986 notre victoire commune
ce ne sera pas
ce ne sera pas la victoire des uns sur
les autres ce sera d'abord celle de nos
convictions
ce sera d'abord celle du bon sens et
celle du renouveau voilà ce que signifie
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
votre présence c'est comme un valéry
giscard d'estaing se félicitera lui
aussi de l'union retrouvée pour mieux
attaquer le gouvernement et notamment au
sujet des modifications apportées aux
intérêts de l'emprunt qui porte son nom
on ne gouverne pas un grand pays par des
coups fourrés
jamais dans son histoire financière
la france n'a manqué à sa signature et
je vous dirai simplement ceci un
gouvernement sans paroles c'est un
gouvernement sans confiance
fin de l'acte 2 à joinville on
retrouvera une partie des personnages
pour l'acte iii deux heures plus tard à
laval dans la mayenne les barriste du
père sont au rendez vous pour écouter
raymond barre critique et est proposé
son union à lui en 1900 ce dont les
français sont vraiment fatiguées
ce sont des combines des combines passé
et combine présente et des combines à
venir
j'ai vécu dans mes fonctions de premier
ministre
une situation dont je me souviens
comment voulez-vous que moi qui ai vécu
8 981
je n'aspire pas bhl toutes mes forces à
l'union mais à la vraie union ayant
parlé le dernier dans la journée raymond
barre a pu une fois de plus se poser en
donneur de leçons et avoir le bronze
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et du budget pierre bérégovoy a tenu à
répliquer aux accusations de valéry
giscard d'estaing en ce qui concerne la
modification du régime fiscal de
l'emprunt qui porte son nom
que messieurs giscard d'estaing barré
chirac ait trouvé comme seul terrain
d'entente la défense d'un privilège
fiscal démontre la vanité de leurs
discours sur la solidarité nécessaire en
temps de crise déclare pierre bérégovoy
qui reproche à l'ancien chef de l'état
de s'en tenir à des contre vérités à
propos de l'emprunt de son côté le porte
parole du gouvernement roland dumas a
dénoncé tout à l'heure ce qu'il appelle
le toyboy de l'opposition à ce sujet
dénonçant dénonçant le soi-disant
manquement à la parole de l'état affirme
roland dumas l'opposition vise surtout à
détourner l'attention du public d'une
opération financière chaque jour plus
désastreuses qui aura coûté 16 fois plus
qu'elle n'aura rapporté at il dit il y
ajouter les termes du contrat sont
scrupuleusement respectés par le vote de
l'assemblée nationale à l'étranger les
deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle américaine fourbissent
leurs armes dans quelques heures ce soir
doit avoir lieu le dernier débat
télévisé de la campagne électorale pour
walter mondale qu'ils avaient dominée en
ald reggane dans le premier débat mais
qui reste loin derrière
dans les intentions de vote c'est le
débat de la dernière chance pour ronald
reagan c'est l'occasion de défendre avec
brio sa politique étrangère surtout en
amérique centrale et vis-à-vis de
l'union soviétique
edouard leur invisible depuis 48 heures
ronald reagan et les principaux membres
de son état majeurs sont restés enfermés
dans un bureau de la maison blanche où
l'on à reconstituer le décor du studio
où se déroulera le débat que ce soir un
travail minutieux
d'autant plus qu'il se retrouve pour la
deuxième et dernière fois vieux set face
à un adversaire qu'on s'est révélé être
beaucoup plus redécollé à ce genre
d'exercice walter mondale vainqueur de
quelques points puis débat consacré à la
politique intérieure il y à exactement
deux semaines
et si on estime que le débat de ce soir
ici à kansas city va déterminer le choix
que les américains auront à faire le 6
novembre
c'est bien parce que les éléments qui
entrent en jeu sont considérables le
thème du débat d'abord la politique
étrangère ou ronald reagan n'y est pas
très à l'aise surtout lorsque l'on parle
du proche-orient de beyrouth ou de
l'amérique centrale
salvador nicaragua avec là bas les
dernières maladresse de la cia et puis
il ya aussi la longueur du débat une
heure et demi c'est long très long
la dernière fois le président semblait
très fatigué mais ce qui de toute façon
ne l'empêchent pas de distance est
largement son adversaire si l'on en
croit le dernier sondage en date celui
de ce matin qui donne à ronald régal une
avance de 21 points sur walter mondale
en pologne l'émotion est vive après
l'annoncé hier de la disparition d'un
prêtre de 37 ans le père popieluszko
l'un des plus ardents et les plus
populaires défenseur de solidarité il a
été enlevé vendredi dernier par des
inconnus près de torun au nord du pays
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
manifesté ce matin à gdansk pour exiger
sa libération et les valises à s'est
rendu à voir ce vie pour aller prier
dans sa paroisse michel sous l'eau vichy
le père popieluszko lors d'un l'office
du dimanche dans sa paroisse de saint
stanislas
aumônier des asi vie de la banlieue de
varsovie
il s'est toujours opposé aux efforts
qu'elles qu'en soient les risques à la
normalisation du général jaruszalski
bête noire du régime polonais les
autorités avaient déjà tenté l'hiver
dernier de l'intimider par des
poursuites judiciaires pour abus de
sacerdoce à des fins politiques
depuis il était constamment suivi
pendant ses déplacements par des
policiers en civil que son enlèvement
avait pu échapper à cette vigilance de
tous les instants est pour le moins
étrange aussi ce matin l'atmosphère
était particulièrement grave et tendue
lors de cette messe célébrée sans lui
dans son église de saint stanislas
les valises à amis du prêtre enlevé
considère cette disparition comme une
suite de la violation des accords dans
ce que doute 80 signé alors par le
gouvernement et solidarnosc le syndicat
dissous par les autorités à créer
aujourd'hui un comité de soutien à
l'aumônier kidnappé et dans toutes les
grandes villes du pays des veillées de
prières ont commencé ce soir à son
initiative revenons à l'actualité en
france avec l'arrestation d'un braqueur
bien connu de la police alain teixeira
teixeira est soupçonné d'avoir été le
complice de cherves de serge lefebvre
appréhender aussitôt après la fusillade
de puteaux qui a coûté la vie le 11
octobre dernier au brigadier joseph leon
explosion à bordeaux ce matin et un
boulanger a été tué par une bombe ce
n'est pas lui qui était visé mais
semble-t-il un bar voisin dans le
quartier du port
le cinéaste pierre kast vient de mourir
à l'âge de 62 ans il avait été l'un des
brillants cinéaste français de la
nouvelle vague avec notamment le bel âge
et la morte saison des amours
maintenant avant de vous donner les
résultats du tiercé de vous parler du
temps de demain je vous propose de
rejoindre robert chapatte qui va revenir
bien sûr sur la victoire d'alain prost
est aussi la victoire de niki lauda
et oui et quelle formidable course
poursuite livrée par l'audace sur prost
à l'occasion de ce grand prix du
portugal décisif pour l'attribution du
titre de champion du monde pour prost en
tête il ne fallait pas que l'aude a
terminé deuxième et pourtant l'eau
d'ajustement y est parvenu après avoir
pris le départ en 13e position
lauda champion du monde donc pour la
troisième fois gérard holtz sur place
quel spectacle aujourd'hui à estoril
même les avions piqué du nez pour voir
ça temps superbe piste sèche un circuit
tourmenté mais que tous les pilotes
trouvent intéressant côté numéro 7
alain prost tension la concentration des
grands jours les très grands jours pour
le français c'est peut-être la course de
sexe
côté numéro 8 côté niki lauda
décontraction l'autrichien est
incroyablement détendue
non pas de problème tout le monde est
tellement nerveux la seule solution pour
moi si je veux gagner c'est rester
calmes
madame lauda marlène est même venu
encourager son mari rarissime
le départ en première ligne pickett et
prost dans la ligne droite des stands et
keke rosberg le finlandais qui sera le
plus astucieux et le plus rapide
il a passé à droite
rosberg prend la tête devant nigel
mansell alain prost et nelson piquet
piquette va faire un tête-à-queue il va
rétrograder rosberg est en tête
lauda est loin derrière en 10e position
pour moi ça a été la course la plus
difficile
alain prenant la tête très tôt pendant
la course donc pour gagner le
championnat je devais terminer deuxième
il a vraiment fallu me remuer le après
plusieurs tentatives prost double
rossberg la voie est libre
alain prost s'envole il ne sera jamais
rattrapé
ans
pour niki lauda les problèmes commencent
devant lui c'est la place de la concorde
à six heures du soir un trafic fou alors
l'autrichien attaque pas facile
c'était très difficile
j'ai tenté ma chance j'ai pris des
risques ça a marché dieu merci j'ai pu
terminer deuxième comment il s'y est
pris
simple regardez ils passent johan sonne
il passe alboreto il passe sénat route
lui continue son cavalier seul
il augmente même son avance sur ses
poursuivants c'est-à-dire mansell et
lauda à cet instant il est même champion
du monde en deuxième position nigel
mansell fait une course superbe
le moteur renault de sa lotus fonctionne
à merveille mais les freins vont lâcher
c'est le dernier coup de théâtre de la
saison 84 membres seuls abandonne alain
prost n'est plus champion
je suis vraiment très très désolé pour
l'unss si ma voiture avait marché
correctement
il aurait été champion du monde
évidemment pour nikki c'est bon mais il
est dommage que cela se soit passé de
cette façon victoire d'alain prost pour
ce grand prix du portugal
septième victoire de la saison pour le
numéro 7 chez mclaren on exulte saison
parfaite
ils ont tout gagné niki lauda deuxième
de ce grand prix remporte donc le titre
de champion du monde en succédant à
nelson piquet est sur le podium
lauda est licite prost et m'a dit et
qu'il est vraiment très très chanceux
cette année que qu'il allait m'aider à
gagner les prochaines et que j'étais
vraiment il était malheureux pour moi
c'est très simple et le tout en vitesse
de pointe à plus de 300 à l'heure et
maintenant avec bernard père s'est vu
marquer l'étranger pas de but italien
cette fois mais sachez que rome et deron
ont fait match nul 0 à 0
quant à la yuv elle a gagné par 3 1 à
crémone un but de michel platini rda
yougoslavie voilà qui doit intéresser
les footballeurs français puisqu'il
s'agit là de deux des prochains
adversaires de la france en championnats
du monde
et pourtant tout avait très bien
commencé pour la rda les petits jeux
puisque dès la 12e minute club est ce
qui avait ouvert
la marque pour la rda mais quelques 18
minutes plus tard bazdarevic
le numéro 10 va faire un très bon numéro
personnel résisté à plusieurs charges et
du pied droit égalisé 1 partout c'est la
marque à la mi-temps deuxième mi-temps
attaques des yougoslaves avec un numéro
extraordinaire de ces stich le numéro 7
regardez bien fixe la défense
un superbe centre en retrait pour votre
cri 2 1 pour la yougoslavie
dès lors les allemands de l'est vont se
ruer à l'attaqué et réussir
l'égalisation la 51e minute un but
superbe de haynes à montrer dans les
écoles mais 29 minutes plus tard c'est
stich à nouveau va marquer très bien
servi par son capitaine zayed
sur une contre attaque c'est si tu pars
dans le dos des défenseurs allemands et
d'un avantage à la yougoslavie qui avait
été tenu en échec sur son terrain par la
bulgarie donc 3 à 2 pour la yougoslavie
en fin de match verde a va avoir une
bonne occasion d'égaliser mais ce
n'était pas son jour la rda s'incline 3
à 2 regardez à un genou à terre et a
fortement compromis ses chances de
qualification même en saison de feuilles
mortes la natation ne prend pas de
vacances avec les boucles de la marne
nage avec palmes c'est une classique qui
aujourd'hui par une température idéale
n'a pas fait regretter le déplacement
sur les bords de marne brigitte
duvauchelle
un peu de talent qu un peu de graisse
pour que la combinaison devienne une
seconde peau
paris
on la gonfle pour qu'elles se tendent
bien
c'est le règne de la monopalme plus
performante que la bi palmes et bissala
dinosaures oui ou mono il ne reste plus
qu'à fermer les yeux pour se jeter à la
marne s'est passé pour eux simplement
cette perte quand on connaît nos polluée
à lévis 103 participants silence pour
les 21e boucles de la marne dernière
épreuve du championnat d'europe 10 km de
sang autour de sa mort
c'est l'italien vendit ni qui détient le
record en 1h02 le jeune français silva
florio prend un très bon départ et
nagent à côté du champion italien
la monopalme c'est là que sirène plus de
surface plus de pression sur l'eau plus
de vitesse
ondulations du corps c'est la nage du
dauphin
ce sous marin avec périscope c'est le
carabinier italien avants dit ni au
style très cool et qui prend la tête
larguant le reste du peloton
tous les cinq ou six battement les
concurrents lève la tête pour rectifier
leurs trajectoires ils doivent aussi se
méfier des courants
aulu bandini remporte les boucles de la
marne et devient champion d'europe
belle performance du français silva
florio qui termine deuxième mona
pétillot vous en reprendrez bien une
goutte avec daniel kazan une autre
sélection si j'ose dire celle des flashs
du jour pour compléter ce stade de
deuxième décidément l'espagne réussit au
belge claude criquelion déjà champion du
monde ici même au mois de septembre
criquelion a enlevé la course de côte
devant l'espagnol gorospe et dernier
grand prix de la saison en formule 3 sur
le circuit de jarama l'écossé johnny
dumfries l'emportent devant le danois
niels haine et le français bernard
quental mais c'est l'italien ivan
capelli qui est champion d'europe de
formule droit devant le vainqueur du
jour johnny dumfries santa légumes
de fait jean paul belmondo entre deux
tournages il s'amuse et ben à la
prochaine
cascade de mauvais coup à singapour
entre chiliens et argentins dans la
grisaille
un joli but argentin mais au coup de
sifflet final sombre règlement de
comptes entre les joueurs des deux
équipes
merci messieurs pour cette belle
propagande pour le football un qui s'est
trompé d'adversaire il a frappé un
coéquipier dernière nouvelle finale 100%
française aux championnats du monde de
karaté disputé à maastricht
emmanuel pinda a battu patrice rullier
raw en toutes catégories par 6 à 4 beau
bilan français puisque l'équipe de
france a récolté deux médailles d'or
avec celle de sophie berger une d'argent
et quatre de bronze retour au journal
maintenant retrouvant christine ockrent
a dit mot et robert avec les résultats
du tiercé les résultats du tiercé qui se
courait aujourd'hui un long chant à
l'arrivée vous les voyez le 5 le 14 et
le 19 d'assez gros 9 doors rapport 5
francs dans l'ordre 40 2365 francs dans
un ordre différent 8473 fond et
maintenant alain gillot-pétré va nous
parler du temps de demain au pas de
course jules heures je vous apporte de
la douceur de la douceur océane problème
c'est que vous apporte aussi des nuages
regarder la carte de demain c'est assez
simple la carte wi sur la moitié ouest
en milieu de journée beaucoup de nuages
me des pluies très modérée modérée
tandis que sur la moitié est eh bien ce
sera du beau temps en attendant bien
entendu les nuages que des températures
ça ne bouge pas de 14 à 16 degrés sur la
moitié nord et de 15 à 21 degrés sur la
moitié sud à leurs pics ne bouge pas
passons demain c'est le lundi 22 octobre
nous aurons quatre minutes de ses rayons
à lever 7h21 coucher 17h47 et bonne fête
à toutes les [ __ ] mais je la porte
sur un plateau si je puis dire et
rapidement encore la présentation d'un
nouveau magazine science numéro 1 qui
s'adresse à tous ceux qui s'intéressent
à la science sous toutes ses formes
voilà je vous rappelle
la nouvelle la plus triste de cette
journée la mort de françois truffaut
françois truffaut est mort cet après
midi il avait 50 de gens à 23h20 hervé
claude vous présentera notre dernier
journal demain 12h45 antenne 2010 18h30
c'est la vie et à 20h vous retrouverez
bernard rapp très bonne soirée à la
semaine prochaine